all right in this video we're talking
about the short answer section of the ap
u.s history exam
in the first part of this video we
talked about the first two sections of
this question which asked for examples
of how contact with europeans changed
native american society and the three
most important things we talked about
were first
that you really have to pay attention to
the
timeline given to you in the question
because you don't want to give an answer
that's outside of that time frame so
only talk about the period from 1492 to
1700 nothing after that the second thing
we mentioned is that there could be all
sorts of right answers to this question
so choose the things that you know best
and feel most qualified to talk about
and third if you're stuck
consider how a certain issue might
affect people differently of different
races different classes and different
genders you might find a new example
when considering those that will help
you answer a more difficult question all
right let's move on to the last part of
this question
for part c we're now looking for kind of
a counter example a way that native
americans resisted changes brought on by
europeans in this time period
now you might be tempted to talk about
the ghost dance but remember that the
ghost dance wasn't until the end of the
19th century that's the 1880s 1890s so
it's way outside the scope of our time
period here ending at 1700. so we're
thinking back to the early period of
contact the early colonial period so
what are some examples of resistance to
change in this time period well i think
an obvious example would be war
many native americans went to war
against european invaders some good
examples of this might be
king phillips war
in
new england
or maybe pope is rebellion in the west
let me give us a little bit more space
to write here
these are two really specific examples
and i would recommend that you give
specific examples whenever possible even
though it's not necessary at times but
it will show that you really know what
you're talking about
another example of resistance might be
going against some of the things we've
talked about earlier so labor for
example well not all native americans
were part of an encomienda system some
of them chose to flee
it's one of the reasons why europeans
resorted to african slavery in this time
period because native americans knew the
landscape very well and could get away
when someone tried to enslave them you
could also talk about some cultural
resistance to european ways for example
a refusal to convert to christianity
many native americans
were
targeted by
missionaries who were coming to the new
world specifically to
convert native americans to christianity
along with getting very wealthy of
course but in many cases native
americans outright refuse to convert to
christianity or they may have
incorporated christianity into their own
previous beliefs so any of these are
good options and i should think two out
of the three of these are fairly simple
i think
disease
and also warfare
are things that are going to come to
mind right away when we think about this
early period of contact
it's the second example that's really
going to make you reach and for that i
recommend this strategy of considering
race class and gender because among one
of them there's definitely going to be
something that is relevant
so remember any of these answers is
correct you only need to choose the ones
that you know and all you need to do is
write one sentence about each of these
options
keep yourself short simple and to the
point answer the question and move on